(audience cheering)
- Welcome back y'all.
A few years ago, our next guest signed a
record-setting podcast deal
worth 60 million dollars.
(audience cheers)
What?
Now with over 5 million
listeners each week,
her show has been the second
most popular podcast on Spotify
for the last two years. (horn noise)
The show is Call Her Daddy.
It's a feminist forward
celebrity interview show where
guests often feel safe enough
to be vulnerable and honest
which is cool.
New episodes premiere Wednesdays
exclusively on Spotify.
Everybody say hello to Alex Cooper.
(audience cheers)
(energetic music)
They're going nuts for you!
- They're Daddy Gang!
(audience cheers)
- Congratulations on all
the success of the podcast.
Did you see that happening?
- You know, I hoped for it.
- Yeah dreamed it, yeah.
- When you start something
you're like, "I hope"
But also I was at one point
like doing it in my parent's basement.
Like, you're like, "I hope this tracks."
And then the success truly feels
like still to this day
I'm like, "Pinch me."
I'm like, where am I?
I'm on "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
Like I'm the biggest
fan, just so you know.
- Oh my God, thank you!
- My first ever concert was you.
- Don't.
(audience cheers)
- Atlantic City, yeah, yeah.
- Are you serious?
- First ever show, my best
friend from childhood, Kristen,
my sister, and my mom,
we went to Atlantic City.
Breakaway.
- I remember that tour, yeah.
- Oh, I was like thriving.
I think I peaked in that moment.
But yes, I'm a huge fan.
(Kelly laughing)
I love you. I love you. Bow down bow down.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Love you.
- Well, I have to ask- Thank you.
But I have to ask you,
where did you come up with
Call Her Daddy?
- Okay. So I know it's such-
- 'Cause it seems kind of funny.
- Yes, everyone, especially
my grandmother used to be like
"What is the show name?"
I'm like, "Grandma, just listen."
And I know.
- Yeah
- So Call Her Daddy was
really, I think the connotation
of the word "Daddy" in America
is like a man that's a boss
and powerful and rich and
successful and a leader.
And I was like, let's
flip the gender roles.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm the daddy too.
And so we changed it to Call Her Daddy.
- [Kelly] I like it!
(audience cheers)
I love it actually.
- Yeah.
- So you, you signed reportedly
the biggest podcast deal
in history for a woman.
That's insane.
(audience cheers)
I'm gonna lead with that.
It's 60 million dollars.
So like what, what was
your path to getting
to that kind of success?
Because other people are like,
"I'm gonna start a podcast tomorrow."
- Yeah. It's a lot of work.
I'm not gonna sugarcoat it and be like,
"Ah, easy peasy."
- [ Kelly] Yeah.
- It was a lot of work
but I will say it was the
most rewarding thing because
I've always been so passionate
about creating content
and so I was fortunate
that I was kind of able to take my passion
and turn it into my purpose and do this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I will say throughout-
- That's a gift, not everybody has that.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Yeah.
- I will say though,
something I think that's very
very unique about my
situation is my relationship
to my audience.
The Daddy Gang who's in
the stands, love you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- But truly like I,
everything I do for the show
has always been for them.
And we have this like
very deep connection.
Like when I'm on the
street, my mom will be like,
"Oh my God is that a
friend from high school?"
I'm like, "No Mom, that's Daddy
Gang we met 15 seconds ago.
She's telling me about her
breakup with her boyfriend
because of the show", like,
we just have this bond,
- [ Kelly] Yeah!
- And I think it's because
of how intimate the
show is, so I think the-
- You're conversational.
- Yes, and I think that's why
it's been successful is like
it's like a family and it
doesn't feel like a show.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh, I love it.
So more recently you did a docu-podcast.
This is super cool, about women's rights
titled "An Abortion Story".
Can you tell us about that
and why you wanted to make it,
why you felt it was important?
- So I think we all see
people online, you know
influencers who I think
are trying to do a good job
but sometimes people are
just reposting things when
something in the news is
happening and they're trying to
support, but it's like,
did you do the research?
Like do you know what that means?
Do you know actually what's behind that?
Do you know the organization?
So when Roe v. Wade was
overturned, I just felt
like I have the biggest female podcast.
There was a bit of-
- And you're female.
- Yes. Yes.
So there was a responsibility
that I felt personally
connected to of, I'm not here
to tell anyone what to believe
and what to do, but I,
what I wanted to do was to
create a piece of content that
would be thought-provoking
and just have people think
about what's going on
in the world.
How do you feel about it?
I didn't ask for anything.
And so I went and I flew to
North Carolina and I went
to a health clinic that
was giving women abortions
in North Carolina just to
understand what was going on.
And it took me a few months to do this.
I wanted to make sure I did the research.
I wasn't putting out false information.
I wanted to be as unbiased as I could be.
And just be there.
- Because it sucks because
there is so much news out there
and you don't know who to trust.
- [Alex] Yes, yes.
- Yeah.
- And I recognize people
come to Call Her Daddy
to just have a good time and to connect.
And this was the first
project that I ever did,
truly that was
way more intense and very serious
and a little bit more on the side of like,
"Oh, Alex like you're getting
into certain territory."
And I'm like, as women,
I think we should just
have the conversation.
Let's just talk about it.
Let's, let's not-
(audience clapping)
- Not forcing an answer but like-
- Yeah! Yeah that's all.
- I like that, that's what I,
people always say to, you know
steer away from, from politics or faith.
But I enjoy those conversations most times
because I like learning.
I like knowing why you feel so
adamant one way or the other.
I think, I think that's how
you learn and we progress
- And I think you just
have to learn to respect.
Like we all clearly have an idea
of why we believe something.
You have to respect both
sides to try to come
to common ground.
And that's what I tried to do.
I'm like, I'm not gonna put a PSA of like
this is what you need to do.
Like, just watch it.
And then if you're still-
if you believe one thing
or another, great.
It's just at least you know,
you made an educated decision
on how you feel.
Not just based off of what
your parents taught you
or what you saw online.
Like how do you feel about the situation?
Make an educated decision.
- Educate yourself. Yeah.
Yeah. Well we need another break.
You can listen to Alex's podcast
Call Her Daddy exclusively on Spotify.
New episodes premiere Wednesdays.